are you okay
[Music]
oh hey sorry guys we're uh rolling we're
talking about you're not gonna believe
us talking about ayahuasca
i'm sorry i it's once you once once
it once you've uh engaged did i
this is a very funny ayahuasca story yes
so last
two weeks ago did i tell the story about
my mom
yeah yeah she was she
the her email where i just tell us so i
i
i had a good i i connected with my mom
in the spirit world
uh under the influence of ayahuasca and
uh and
told her about it she was fine with it
like not fine with it she was like
great she was like you know made my day
get a she sent me a follow-up email
because that's the only way i talked to
my mom is via email uh
my assistants reach out i'm kidding um
and
she basically was like want to reiterate
how
how touched i was about what you said
and is do you think
all of your brothers and sisters could
do it wow
at the same time i think she's kidding
but also like not
no she's not kidding which would be like
uh
it would be a record i think can you
imagine the next family reunion like
how many people can get punched in the
face i got punched in the face at a
family
guys we've all been there you said it um
do you think you could actually do a
sibling retreat thing
yeah the weirder one would be
uh my mom because she's 87. so that
would be the hard
that's like i don't even know what what
they would suggest
no but i just mean with your siblings
would do you think all of them
could be open one of them went one of
them apparently did it like a decade ago
and
uh was so overcome by the noise that he
had to bounce
how do you bounce from ayahuasca he
bounced from a retreat in like
oh peru or something when it was done he
when he came down before it was yeah he
did i
uh this is secondhand so he did it twice
two nights in a row
and people's uh purging was too loud
and he had to go
so he would have not been able to hang
at the ocean thunderdome yeah
where we were don't come to rock's
rental
rocks rental you never make it at rocks
rental
um now uh how was your week darling
hey it's good do you remember any of it
did you talk about it
i should have been i should have spent
the last 20 minutes thinking of
what i did but oh oh i went to i went to
a black art exhibit
called shattered glass great um great
fantastic
at the jeffrey deutsch gallery
so check and um
that's all i remember great what did you
do
i didn't do like
like in terms of activities i don't
think i did much
i worked on a script and uh
you know walked around where did you
walk
you don't scoot anymore do you i scooted
yesterday yesterday was the first first
time
since you bought it no i i use it more
than you'd think
it's um death defying can you do you
wear a helmet at least no
too cool i'm going to die first of all
i'm not going to die
i mean i'm going to die but it's not
going to change
uh death is a common not a period now
look guys when you
you're listening to the internet's
number one spiritual podcast
uh we'll be right back right after this
um
so let's get into the the the earth the
earth week
the exterior of the terrestrial
terrestrial earth
so we were talking before so about the
the
asian uh massage parlor
parlor i don't love the word parlor i
love the word parlor it feels old-timey
right it's
cute if it's ice cream but if it's if
it's
parlor just sit in my parlor yeah but i
don't like when it's like
a parlor i don't know it just seems
old-fashiony like a photography part
like a parlor and then the guy takes
pictures with the cloth over his head
it's it's i don't like it with don't
touch me
in a parlor don't physically touch me
in a parlor i guess that's what i'm
saying uh so the kid's name is robert
aaron long
uh and he shot up eight people
um and six of them were asian women
uh and one other one other person was
wounded
um and now
the the the way
most of the media talked about it was
there was a there was a hate there was a
rush to this is a hate crime
with no room for anything else
uh my first thought was
this is a sex work issue and then
my second thought was this is a
religious oppression issue
because i think he would not have killed
them if they worked at a restaurant
do you know what i mean it wasn't like i
hate asians it was
i'm sexual repression has made me
[ __ ] insane no i think that when
people are saying it was
jessica doesn't qualify exactly as a
hate crime doesn't mean
i'm not saying don't prosecute this i
like prince i think that's the
issue i don't think they can it doesn't
like i don't know there's some weird
criteria but i think people are saying
that the
bare minimum five facebook posts to get
a to get a hate crime beef
um right how many look at his tweets um
i think it was that asian women are so
sexualized and
like dehuman dehumanized that way so
then of course
it's just like an undertone do you know
what i mean yeah
just because you could i know what you
mean it's not just because
he has sex with them he can't hate them
i just see it as
there's a lot of people who kill black
prostitutes is that
maybe he isn't maybe it's not on the
forefront racially motivated but it is
like
this underbelly of society just there
was racism all throughout
it you know yeah i get it
i don't know that my mind went to if sex
work was legal
uh they probably
after he shot up one place the other
places would have been like
alerted because he shot up three places
right
right um and like
two yeah three places i feel like there
would have been more information
again there they could have bolted the
door i don't [ __ ] know right
um i think if they were had been
white prostitutes he uh or massaged
um uh if they have been white latino
i think he would have killed them just
as much the bigger issue
which then leads lends to
why are asian women
why is it only an asian woman thing that
do those jobs yeah that's just one of
those like
it's it's like part racism part like
they're hiring
it's part racism parts it's just very
like exploitive
sex like all the things um
what's weird though is i was
me and my friend were thinking of
writing something and we were doing
research
and i said you know there's a reason why
most there's not a lot of
um she wanted to make it a strip club
setting and i said i think there's a
reason why there's almost no strip club
shows because it's really hard
to not to do it's like a fine dance of
like not exploiting not making fun of
right um so then i just started doing
research in strip clubs
and there's so much violence at strip
clubs there's so
much there's so many incidences of
people
killing strippers that they
i don't know they take out another thing
it's like is a
it's a can can it be a hate crime that's
not based on race that's gender
gender-based i mean i you could almost
say that
it's hard to just violence against women
it's rarely
uh independent
of their gender do you know what i mean
it's always never it's
yeah like i don't want to say 100 of the
time because i'm sure there's somebody
out there is
doing bad stuff to women just for the
love of doing bad stuff to anybody
there's a richard ramirez that it's like
everybody can get it every y'all get
some everyone wants them gets them
okay uh yeah but no yeah
but i think but it the other thing
that's annoying it's just silly
in that this week because of coronavirus
or this year
you can only say it's a hate crime and
not
the because it we're only covering that
issue we what about
sex work we're not now because occur
because trump called it the china virus
we're not covering that
how about the weird the guy went to a
religious
rehab ah we're not gonna cover that
in terms of like the what contributed to
it and then
when christopher wray and that other and
the cops said it doesn't seem racially
motivated
they get screamed at culturally
right and it's like ah
i just people going it's only what i
think it is i don't they investigate the
[ __ ]
i think with the with the the atlanta
cop you go
he the atlanta was racist atlanta like
he's scott he's been on
yeah he's raises he's got the post he's
got the five points yeah
um and but like chris wray
well the problem is when you
i feel like in the last few months we're
hearing more about
asian hate and south asian before this
happened right yeah
so we talked about it before that
happened right
we bought the we bought them away we've
been taking asians a long time
we bought them we got the trunk we were
out the trunk
um soon people are gonna be what's a
mixtape and what's a trunk
i know what a frunk is because that's
what tesla's having that's what
everybody i know drives
i saw somebody young i saw a pose that
someone asked
what's burning a cd mean yeah
[Music]
moving on yeah um so but when i did that
research i didn't realize
how much violence
um sex workers get obviously when i say
sex workers it kind of feels like
dodgy hand jobbies prostitution thing
but even
strippers you know there's so much
violence that happens at strip clubs
i mean i was researching it and like
some dude did a crossbow into a strip
club and was like
shooting off strippers and we don't
really hear about it because it's such
like an underbelly
and we don't want to talk about it
because like when
serial killers kill prostitutes it's
like makes the least noise you know um
so i think there's a balance of course
when it's all asian women
right now it's just like the sweet spot
of like okay yeah we should also talk
about why we're
the funniest part is there was a guy
there getting a massage who got popped
that's the [ __ ] funny i mean funny
yes it's funny you're getting a massage
it you go from
pure relaxation to the absolute opposite
with it it's fantastic
10 seconds this guy's here in the
[ __ ]
the river bed soundtrack
to probably naked if it's
if he's getting jerked off i would
assume they're naked and getting shot at
it's the worst scenario worst case
scenario worst case for
worst thing adam at a massage parlor
um not a great yelp review no
one star one star got shot uh
[Music]
okay so now but there is
an influx of asian hate during corona
yeah but i think it's possible
i just mean maybe what i mean is maybe
we don't
take it was racially moving off the
table immediately
right you know what i mean yeah i don't
yeah i do you know
i know what you mean but that's no what
that what like a
uh uh fact a literally an evidence-based
group is
meant to do it's not christopher rae's
job to read the cultural temperature and
be like what should i say
this what would what would a lot of
media and people on twitter
like this to be of course not i'm saying
why
say well it wasn't racially motivated
immediately because sometimes you don't
know sometimes we have to look at like
oh there were tweets we talked to people
we talked to his name's like oh well he
did say you know that's when you come
funny thing about that kid is there's
somebody quoted
as saying like there was a thing when
they were in high school
and somebody used the n-word and the kid
was like
robert allen whatever was robert downey
jr
um robert aaron long was like
pissed right so we that's what i'm
saying like
i'm not nitpicking anyway i guess i'm
just my
beef is with solving the wrong problem
the other my other issue with asian hate
is
it's one thing if cops are beating up
black people or killing black people
uh you the cops technically work for us
right i
get how to change that if a bunch of
[ __ ]
psychopaths are fighting asian people
i don't know what to do i have no idea
what to do
i don't know how to stop the next robin
aaron long i don't know how anyone does
so
when there was a couple people dm me
like i we need you to speak out i'm like
have i been for it right what do you
need me to how many people think i'm
for it okay so what good does
up tweet or any of that that's almost a
different argument but
i don't know how to stop uh
asian hate because i don't even
understand
the premise of it other than they're
they are they're they're they look
different
than me that's all you really need for
hate right i mean
but but at least with with uh
black racism it's like slavery i yeah i
get it
like i absolutely get it i don't even
know the premise
of asian hate other than they
right my issue with the whole thing
is that we're
we're really we're really rounding up on
asian hate
like stop asian hate i feel like
doesn't address so many issues
in the world of asian hate you know like
there is a lot it's so much more new
you've ever stopped saying asian hate so
much no no that's what they're calling
it oh
i know what you keep saying the thing
about asian hate is asian no no
the way i'm just saying like anti-asian
stop asian
i'm just talking about this the the i'm
talking about the hashtag
right stop asianhate okay the hashtag
of stop asianhate is
glossing over a lot and just saying this
kind of catchy stop
asian hate okay direct clear
got it but i it the actual issue is so
much more nuanced and we're not talking
about it there's a lot of
one asian okay so that's persia
iran to you know uh
the philippines yes but but and that's
also by the way an argument about where
it stops because i remember somebody
saying like kamala harris is asian now
and right i don't what else what else
i'm technically asian i'm not sitting
here you know it's like you kind of
gotta
we're really oh iran is is it asia yeah
yeah
turkey yeah to
east whatever i don't know east
turkey to east turkey east did we go to
the turkey
um will pulls up asia yeah
great uh russia is asia that's always a
fun one
but there's a lot of uh yeah russians
russians count it's asia i mean that's
for the funniest like
yeah well also if you go around like all
the stan countries
i'll stop hating russians fine you got
me can you
wait you hacked it fine i won't hate use
becky's
um so the problem is that okay
so asian hate this hashtag it's like
stop european hate okay
uh what so it's really it glosses over a
lot also there's
so much hate inside the asian community
you can't even can't even broach it
me i'm not saying don't do it here this
is if
of course if you're gonna do it anywhere
this is the point welcome but
you can't even but i'm saying why not
take this opportunity it's a bit of a
black-on-black crime thing
no not really because i think we've had
really
nuanced conversations especially since
blm about all sorts of things like
people talking to their parents
every colorism like everybody's getting
it but why aren't we talking about
the whole picture here because i think
it all
you know you're saying i don't get the
hatred but i think there's so much that
goes into the hatred there's so i'm
there's legislation
passed against chinese americans or
chinese immigrants right
that's there's that's the stuff that
obviously i can change
like we gave japanese reparations like
there's not like i can change it but
you say someone says stop asian hate and
i go
how i just think why aren't we taking
this opportunity to address
like the broader issue you know what i
mean it's just saying
salvation aid okay but what's the
broader issue the broader issue it's
it's so nuanced i mean we're sitting
we're grouping a whole continent
into one hashtag when everybody in that
continent knows
also asia there's like four billion of
you
just stomp us stomp us out
curves i mean you got asia and china you
[ __ ]
boom i stop white hate okay gang
because the minute uh no like that
yeah so it's a lot of i don't yeah that
so even with a nuanced conversation
and they japanese hate korea like or
whatnot
look i'm not the one that's like should
narrate that conversation i'm just
saying
why are we i feel like it does a
disservice to gloss over
all of the um all of the
you know oppression and racism that has
a long history in this country
with the asian community that like why
are we talking about all this
we're just saying we're just talking
about the last symptom stop
doing that thing like you're saying
they're like what is that that you they
don't like them because they look
different but i think if there was more
of a
accomplishment what we didn't like about
them well there's the
no there's the school thing yeah um and
then there was
like a lot of the whole thing i just
feels like it's a very
it feels more marketing and it feels
more like glossed over than
i'm like let's have a real conversation
like but
the the thing that strikes me when you
say let's have a real conversation
is what's
how effective are these conversations
meaning
trump we all have these big
conversations and then trump gets 70
million votes
like what is it are these circle jerks
are we converting
anyone i don't do you think the do you
think after blm
when people were having hard
conversations
eve however performative right i do
think some people had conversations that
they've never had before
at some point yeah you know in this
country i think there was a lot of
older whites who were getting spoken to
by their kids by you know i just think
there was a generational conversation
that happened
can it be really virtue signaling and
like performative yes and can it be
really cringy
yeah but why aren't we i just wonder why
we're
we got into the nitty-gritty when it
came to blm and everyone understood
it went from like the haves like we got
the info
and they have not didn't get it so we're
just like you don't get it blm means
like
yeah it wasn't always black people that
they say that like everyone understood
the point
and they just had to kind of tell people
my question is huh what's the outcome
of this that conversation of the just
the blm conversation
i think okay at minimum
um exposure
some people just got exposed to
knowledge they didn't have before
because it wasn't in their circle it
wasn't
okay but yeah i guess i'm looking for
like downstream like what's the
outcome of the new knowledge other than
i do think now the status quo
i don't think anybody and i don't need a
johnson and johnson to
post blm right but i need that's all i
need
the vaccines come with a blm band-aid um
i think that if you would have said
it it just changes the what we accept
as a narrative i know i feel my
worry not even my worry with all these
things is they're [ __ ]
regional super regional like they're
they're new york la
you know like there's a few and then you
get into specific neighborhoods you get
specific but they were like you could
almost
you know when when um let's say trump
doesn't call it the china virus and
hong kong flu and wonderful ponds like
that
kung flu hong kong what i call kung flu
it's a parody of kung fu
uh just by merit
i believe that you would have gotten 80
of the same
hatred by merit of it starting there
by merit of technically i mean and by
the way the thing that nobody's pointing
out
we should be pummeling bats bat hate
should be higher than it's ever been
they should that should be a hashtag
stop
bad hate um i gotta say [ __ ]
so i i don't understand why
i just don't the you can't uh
disentangle rhetoric from action but
my experience is when something's from
there then people are just mad at that
it doesn't it doesn't sars they didn't
call it uh
bulbasaurs it was that asian that was
avian
asian south asian respiratory syndrome
or something but they called it bird flu
right right uh severe okay well there's
south asian it's severe acute mers is
middle eastern
i whether y it once something's from a
place
i think you're in [ __ ] those people
are in trouble
that are completely interesting do you
remember ebola like no one wanted
african people anywhere
that's what i mean i don't think we
weren't calling it like
unga bunga ebola it was just it's from
africa
right but i don't even know how you
slander africa
um you just did you got i gotcha
um so they
it's like some of the shit's just
bad racist luck do you know what i mean
okay but wait
i don't get what you what i'm saying is
that the i the fact that
asians are getting hatred and people are
trying to link it to
trump in particular or or anyone who
called it kung fulu or anybody who
called it
china virus that's fine
it's fine but it may not be true
wait what do you mean it means what i'm
here's what i mean okay it main
calling it the rhetoric may have
increased
the physical hatred in a
negligible uh amount if or or none
meaning there was no nickname for ebola
that made people want to beat up
africans yeah they just wanted
people like that just want to beat up
africans because they're
they're uh simple-minded people they go
that type of person brought the thing
over here
now i want to beat them up but after 9
11 you can say that
middle eastern hate went up tremendously
absolutely so that was that i would
suggest
was completely because it was 20 middle
eastern guys
right and then and then it was basically
like if you see a middle eastern guy
kick him in the dick right but there was
a lot of rhetoric there was a lot of
like when you hear it absolutely
but by the way that compared to this was
nothing because this is just
a virus do you know what i mean like
i do but i will say during trump hate
just hate crimes were up yeah so what i
agreed in this case
okay i feel like okay the
there were groups that trump directly
marginalized right
yes especially uh latino [ __ ] kind
there's a bunch
i'm not saying he's off the hook i'm not
saying any of this stuff i'm saying
this happens whenever there's a regional
thing right whenever there's a using
ebola
as a thing yeah um and because people
are civil minded they just want to fight
the person who they
the dumbest the imbecile you're saying
this would happen no matter what
country this would happen no matter what
country i'm sure they're having the same
problem in most countries
i could be wrong but what uh
yeah i think asian people have gotten it
pretty bad during corona
yeah all over the country i've seen like
in italy or somewhere in europe where
they were
telling them like get off the track
probably worse yeah in some cases so
but what because they don't speak
english you know what i mean imagine how
bad hatred is when it's in a language
you don't understand like for me
okay goodbye um what
do you what is your point though so
you're saying oh this would have
happened
no matter what okay my point
most of my beefs with the media it's
it's with the idea that
uh trump says a thing and it leads to
this type of behavior in people when
it's like
well that behavior was already there but
that behavior happened
in in for the last hundred years but but
there's
we i i think trump
rhetoric i think black people did did
and even civic peace
oh god let me tell you because i like
because you did too much
[ __ ] countries was like neil you
agree that racism was
up and hate crimes were up during trump
in a way that they weren't
so why so what i'm saying divorcing his
rhetoric from
i'm divorcing his rhetoric from this
because
whenever there's a disease no no i got
the group who gets it
no i get i get that but i'm saying his
rhetoric didn't help so let's say he
said nothing
i still think asian people would have
gotten it and
in this particular case the kid didn't
mention coronavirus the kid didn't
mention i hate those people
the kid didn't mention anything but i
these women uh i believe the words jerk
masturbated me with their hand that's
what he told somebody extravagated me
um he yeah the trump's anti-blacks is
minimal but
it's irrelevant um and the media makes
it this is a hate crime
no questions asked like they're ignoring
it's the thing we can only discuss one
thing and it's going to be the thing
that we are we discussed last week
so this just continuation of the thing
is like
somebody made a really great observation
that
uh the news is like
a trump the meet the the
cnn's down like 45 percent since yeah
since february
have you i don't like i never watched
cnn but no no no it's
like msnbc like everybody is down there
five percent
msnbc's down like 25 fox down like six
percent
um the fox is a counter puncher you
heard it here first
they're better when they're in isolated
yeah 100 um
that the news needs
they need a new product
so they need like trump's gone they're
like what the [ __ ] are we gonna what's
our new product like we gotta
what's our new product what are we doing
next week and i'm not saying that the
that asian hate is fake at all but no
but it seems to all of a sudden be
like the hot new you know it's a hot new
one
it's fine yes i'm actually fine with
that it's just
when there's a story that could be a
bunch of different things they go
we know what it is it's the thing we
said it was last week that was our hot
story
so that's what makes me kind of just
like there are other things here that
are
uh religious oppression isn't going
anywhere meaning religious sexual
oppression making people [ __ ] insane
isn't is gonna be around next year uh
cove asian hatred probably won't be
because covet will be down and
asian people will be back and better
than ever
i you know the problem for me is that i
feel like we're talking about it like
it this the new thing you know like
asian hate it's this new hate and it's
like no
i feel like it's been it's just it's
just a division of racism
yeah it's a it's a sect of racism but i
just feel like
i don't know it just feels conveniently
we're using it right now you know what i
mean like what you're saying and we're
not having the biggest
there's there's i just i'm not saying
don't talk about that it's like
sex work is massive and there's no
it's it's similar to immigration where
they can't
figure out what to do if we make it
league
if we give them a path to citizenship
with uh
with with immigration is that right bad
for
should we make sex work we're too legal
should we prosecute the john
should we pray no everyone's so
uncomfortable we don't want to have that
conversation
it's because it because of religious
because people you know
they're like god when you get to heaven
god asks you about
different uh uh ballot propositions that
you voted for
that's the number one and what why did
you allow that to be legal in your reit
that's what god my god anyway is what
is all about um oh yeah so
uh yeah i don't i the whole thing is
very
i don't know i find it to be because
i've been having like
uh my friends in the bay we talk about
like there's a
like my school i went to was 60 asian
um i went to predominantly asian school
i live in a predominantly asian area
and so a lot of the
issues affecting the asian community are
not foreign to me at all but when i see
it being covered
it's like not even touching things that
i find to be
more interesting and more interesting to
talk about and to educate people that
aren't asian don't live amongst asians
and
are like far removed from the issues
that they have to deal with
and like for example i always have an
issue of the over-sexualization of
asian women and my friends i haven't
contributed that at all
um and i'd be the last person
and i have friends who are who aren't
dainty and
slender and sexy asian women and they
they
feel that weird burden that filipino go
ahead
oh wow not the weed wow
neil cut it out literally caught it out
of the show literally
will please don't air that um
knock it off so
there's just deeper conversations for
example like that like this we
um the the demasculinization of asian
men
you know all these leaves yeah i've got
that i'm guilty of that too literally
a uh buddy of mine i did
it's a great very funny joke okay well
i mean it was you i remember you what a
better week to talk about
it what was that uh the thing about when
there's an interracial couple
it's the the guy is never asian
uh when it's a white and asian oh yeah
no yeah i was like that's 100 true yeah
it's never a white girl with an asian
cup of course
uh you have to be i didn't say i
love this no no but it's a joke it's a
but a buddy of mine an asian buddy of
mine was like
i didn't like that joke oh really wait
why but it's true
because i the neck the punch line was
i've never been in a club and been like
[ __ ] the asian guys are here
oh which is you know you know yes back
this is a long guys this was in
easily seven eight years ago and when
it was gone it was cool um no so like
i feel like asian men are demasculine
that that that
helps this whole thing where i mean
didn't what's his face with his face
cancel cancel comic number three
uh
what do you do louis what have you done
louie did that whole joke how like
asian men are hairless women or
something like that
yeah right right yeah something like
that i think that was from his uh
too hot for tv set too hot for teeps it
was yeah so
we don't really hold each other
accountable to these things you know
what i mean there's
there's a lot of um i think a lot of the
i think white supremacy plagues asian
people just like it does black people in
a different way
you know we don't talk about that like
why aren't we talking about the things
that
and this again isn't even about it
everything gets
hung from the banner of white supremacy
yeah white people didn't see
[ __ ] asian people till 1500 and if
you look at asian history
they were pummeling each other who's
they
chinese japanese korean like they were
[ __ ]
pummeling each other i'm talking about
in america oh right okay i'm just
talking about i'm talking about american
age
okay cause it is not really talking
about the
whole world this movement feels like no
i i agree i just
i guess i'm not like defending the
supremacy everywhere
yeah of course everyone's looking for
the advantage
all the time and right now it's white
people have the advantage
right we're not gonna for much longer
but i'm i intend to live it up inshallah
[ __ ] cut to bits mcmahon walking in
vomiting remember you show me he's gonna
puke um so
that that's the thing like there's thing
also you know
it's an open secret at least where i
grew up that eight older asian people
are very racist against
black people that's the other so and
again this
isn't about
part once you start parsing this [ __ ]
it's endless
it but it's endless ever but if we start
just under
here's the thing i'm not saying let's
find ways to not accept asian hey i'm
saying if we have these
conversations because they don't fully
affect me you know but if we have them
and then we can understand
just where this where things come from i
just think why aren't we understanding
where things come
there's people the amount of ignorant
the amount of ignorance i re i didn't
even realize was out there
during the movement where people like i
didn't know that i didn't know that i'm
like
how the [ __ ] did you not know that yeah
the symptom
is so much easier to solve than the
cause exactly so why symptom being
i mean i wouldn't again i don't call
this i don't think this is
particularly a hate crime if it is it's
way more gendered than
asian just my opinion okay um
but the
people hate each other when they look
different that's a real hard problem
that's a 5 000 year old problem i it's
it's so interesting i mean the thing is
though especially
it's weird to me that immigrants
immigrants had a hard time understanding
blm
the most well because it's like you were
not welcome
by the way they didn't they didn't they
didn't want to understand it that's the
biggest the big the number one issue was
i don't get it right really what
they matter more than me and you know i
i spoke on a um i spoke at like there's
the iranian
harvard like group they they did a panel
and
everyone has at that time everyone felt
the need to speak to their parents
i sent i read a lot of articles um uh
that were like how to speak for young
korean americans how to speak to their
parents about blm young vietnamese
americans how to speak their parents
about beyond like we all had to figure
out not we all but
there was a whole feeling of how do we
explain it to people who
think this is stupid and [ __ ] so i
do
on i just to me it's like yo this isn't
they're not the same the movements are
not the same and they're totally nuanced
in a different way so how do we
yeah i there's another gaping issue
which is
asian people are four percent of the
country um
which is always lower than i think but
they're probably more percentage of the
hate
you know what i mean i don't think it's
even close
i would suggest i think of the hate
crimes hate crimes in the last five
years i would say it's
blacks and jews jews the most the funny
thing is no one talks about it
like so again not even getting into
anti-some medicaid is up the most during
trump
yeah uh do we know
5.9 so sorry six percent um
so statistically there's gonna be more
like they're not that big
it's like uh it's the it's a bad
it's it's a bad argument but it's like
we gotta stop hate
it's the argument that it's the why
don't we stop violence instead of
violence against women
argument of 2019. right that the world
that people loved and you loved
especially uh but it is
not me it was about you it's more
about um dismantling
light sabotage yeah i mean
in essence but we all have to be on the
same page all the immigrants can't be
like
be alive everyone get and also everyone
gets a different week
and everyone it's like dog we gotta stop
hitting each other yeah white people
white people on black but like stop it
we gotta be less
violent like almost nobody was
saying hey leave the middle easterners
alone after
9 11. like yeah no one was like
no one not even like regular woke you
had to be
living on a farm in berkeley yes if you
were
if you saw something say something no
one gave a [ __ ] they were like
like i know i don't trust them why not
this is suspicious
um so his hard hat and his tools
so i don't know what how do we go about
this without feeling because the problem
is it felt performative to me because
i'm like well we're not talking about
the real issue here
at least in my life with with last week
yeah i mean i my real issue is that it's
it's a bunch of [ __ ] but they just made
it one thing and then you're
you seem like you seem like a callous
[ __ ] if you go i think it
it might not be that right [ __ ] you
okay okay
all right what do you what should it
what what should the diagnosis be right
i when you went to crime school tell me
crime stoppers yeah like
i don't and and then it's
uh there's probably still more
black hate than asian hate this week
statistically
i you know what i mean like so but then
again do we so we're so
just because it's a small part of the
property population we're not going to
talk
no i no of course not but what i'm not
saying that's what you're saying
it's very like fat it's it's tick-tock
challenging
now we're doing that stop the agent hey
next week i think it's probably going to
be
back to black people uh if the cops do
something
it'll be back if it's george floyd
verdict if there's anything that
it's again it's like uh hard not to be
cynical not even cynical i guess it's
it's
what's the most effective use of
people's attention and where can you get
the biggest changes if people can affect
legislation that's where you can get
changed
can i stop a psychopath from punching an
old korean lady
i don't think i can but if we
but i do feel like human beings are
influenced by rhetoric
so i don't think this is bad
i think it's good to just
i don't know everyone like this is your
on the record
sheet what are you on the record for
cool blm sign me up okay yeah like gay
rights
okay what else like it doesn't hurt you
to
like clarify your stance on things you
know what i mean even if it is
a cheesy hashtag yeah i don't uh i'm not
saying that's why i didn't tweet her no
no i'm not saying that to you i'm not
even talking to you i'm saying
i get i don't think it hurts i just
think it's
hard i feel like a hypocrite when i
think there's bigger conversations to be
had to actually
get to the root of why there's racism
towards asian people because they have a
different
journey i mean they were you know
there's a like what are the immigration
act of the 70s that invited
asians yeah yeah so that invited agents
to take over like
higher paying job doctors and whatever
there's well that's a different one
that's a different one so those
but i'm just saying there are different
journeys to here obviously chinese
americans have a different
and the weird thing is they probably
hate them people hate
asian different asian groups for
different reasons i don't think they're
that
i think we're giving them more credit no
because i don't it's what are they like
you're a dirt you're a child right
this week it's probably your you gave my
aunt covet okay right
last week it's or whatever last year
it's you're a model you're taking my job
you're better at school you guys are all
that it's just a different
like i feel like though we're saying i
feel like asian people get a different
kind of hatred because they
occupy a different space in america like
they get
sort of elbowed out in a in a guise of
not being racist but they get elbowed
out of
spaces that they are trying to occupy
and like
white people are scared like in ivy
leagues and colleges there's so much
racism towards asians yeah you know
um putting weight on like oh well they
kind of talked about that but
there is like a lot of we don't want all
these ideas
change the laws in california
universities where it went from
uh they were they that black people
fought for affirmative action and
and white people were like that's silly
it should be merit-based
right they made it merit-based after
like
two decades they made a merit-based and
then all the asians came in
because they are better at school than
white people and black people and white
people are like
you know what we need is some
affirmative white affirmative action
and so why aren't i just feel like why
are we not talking about
all of the white
legislation against asian people why are
we talking about the
bigger issue we're talking about well i
don't that's one guy i'm saying
i guess the only thing is i can't affect
punches i don't even think my rhetoric i
don't think i got anybody punched i
don't think i got any you know what i
mean like
i mean i almost got punched but um
uh but like i i don't think i can affect
it
personally could be wrong did i make it
easier for asian guys to get laid
i didn't no i didn't i will i will
acknowledge that
uh that is a [ __ ] up stereotype
that i was promulgating in some ways it
was
on their side because it was like you
would bring attention to it but
well no it's more like the joke i had a
more of a more beats of it where it's
like the how much you have to do as an
asian guy
to get a white girl like you gotta have
a restaurant
and car i mean use the [ __ ] you gotta do
um
so whatever that's but it is still
[ __ ] up
um
[Music]
i don't know how to effect
changes of
that specific group i pray because i
don't think there's a lot of legislation
black people there's legislation what do
you mean against asia yeah
there's a lot there is there's a lot
against infor that can
i just feel like i don't get why the
the the narrative around blm was so much
more like
did you know this did you know this did
you know that white people or black
people
the no black that's what i'm saying
there's so many just
[ __ ] policies cases
that helps people understand so like
when you're
white and get convicted of a crime you
get 11 years when you're black you get
19. like there are so many of those and
this is what i'm talking about
like the stats of it but there are stats
that we're not
i just i i don't know why we're
not talking about how
we're not talking about in a legislative
way or policy change way or because
listen why people also don't as much as
they do as much as they do to keep
black people out of their spaces they
don't love immigrants in their spaces
either i mean in
beverly hills when uh persian people
started moving to la they made laws city
ordinances that
like these properties cannot be owned by
a middle eastern person you can know
hookahs
no no tables of 13.
no belly dancing um so we all get it but
the problem is
no one wants to no one wants to band
together and be like these white people
are tripping
because no one wants to be close to
black no one wants to even
touch get a whiff of blackness on them
well
there's no there's no
incentive for white people to side with
black people no not white sorry like
other
immigrants oh there's like less than
yes because they've i mean first of all
i think they bring racist attitudes
from wherever they're from and then uh
from persia
and uh i think they bring racist
attitudes like everyone's racist
against havoc but everybody benefits
from
anti-black sentiments in america like
other
immigrants non-white people to a point i
mean there's that woman's book who
that thing of like the when racism
against white people hurts everybody
in a lot of cases yeah again i don't i
don't i but i think
to your benefit it's like yeah we all
status yes they
people one of the draw like you get
status above a group
yeah you get status above a group and
the groups buy people
you automatically if you're an immigrant
even if you're just
got here you get seven you get higher
status than
almost all black people so if we're not
gonna get together
everyone's gonna get it at some point
you know and that's what i don't
oh well but they're betting that they uh
they'll avoid it they won't get it
they'll and a lot of them are right i
mean i don't think most persian
people receive are on the not like
they're
not on the receiving end of racism but
they're not on the intensity
no intensely level low it's just like
ignorance like
slander yeah and where's your camel
these things i like these what let me
write them down
he's like this is going in my comedians
of the world
part three so what is this neil's doing
it
just another thing where you get
but you know what though then okay we
can talk about it we can splice it up
and it's not this not that but then
if you're just like a young asian person
seeing a older asian person get punched
in the face and crying
yeah do you want them to not do anything
be like oh i don't know i'm not mad at
anyone's reaction i
just don't know what to do
i don't if i if it comes down to
changing laws like marching to change a
law
[ __ ] i will go there i went
um but if it's about
stopping asian hate it's like
anything vaguer you have a vaguer
policy that i can get behind because
it's so [ __ ] vague it's
it's um it's close to meaningless it's
not meaningless but it's like
dog you got to give me some actionable
[ __ ] to do you know
beyond stop asian hate
you heard it here guys yeah i guess go
on the record here if you listen to the
show
don't hurt asian people how about that
that's about the most that and the
condescension i'm doing this with
implies how silly i think it is that
anyone needs to be told not to do
anything to a specific group i just wish
there was more
like you said i wish there was more call
to action like okay we're in la
they don't really cast asian people in
cool roles here
you know well they love gang member
number three
there's always an asian guy there's
always an asian guy like that really
happens latino guy in the asian guy
because that's
most street gangs like bloods are a
third asian
i just mean no one is like we're gonna
let's we're gonna like it's just a
hashtag
i know but this is that that [ __ ]
numbers game [ __ ]
what there's so many white people here
that if you put a white per people want
to see their race in the movie that's
true
black people want to see their asians
want to see asians so
again people will watch a a black person
perform
they'll watch a few black people perform
do you watch basketball yes they'll
watch
basketball they'll but they don't
there's a
there's a you know eddie murphy denzel
washington it's not will
smith i mean there's actually a lot of
black male star that's a whole other
issue
um don't get me started it's an issue
i'm gonna put an end to it i'll just say
that
i'm gonna preview it on the podcast i'm
gonna um
it's a numbers game that's just a
numbers game but you know what for
example you know what the
every big sport in this country had a
period of time where black people
weren't allowed to perform yeah the
golden the golden age go ahead
one thing that i saw a guy he saw a
thing on
al alden elgin elgin baylor
he died when yesterday did he really
he was uh he was rock's
counter argument to donald sterling
being
racist because rock was like i don't
care he hired the first black gm
elgin baylor yeah what are we [ __ ]
very
very hot asian wife so
who's who's hate who's crying now um so
no elgin
they i just watched a thing on his life
they did kind of like a recap
very interesting and he was he was also
he was one of the first
um black people that played in the nba
at that level like as a star star
position one of the first athletes to
speak out
against you know racism and oppression i
mean this guy is great
i don't know why i brought him up uh oh
i just mean that like
he had a bad i don't like what he did
with his hair later in life neil
he he i'm not gonna bully i'm not gonna
sit here in [ __ ] i don't like i
never liked what he did with his hair
okay it wasn't it's a wig right nice
that's a wig it's uniform but it's a wig
no i think he has like activator on it
or something yeah he's like loosened
okay he might not like what you did with
your hair
who does neil who does
i'm just saying at some point people
like i don't want to watch these people
on my screen
and then they take over and no one
misses you know
yeah it's these are but these are made
massive issues
they're meant to be massive we're not
going to get through so massive like not
going to be covered by a hashtag
yes there's a thing and they only accept
asian people if they're doing karate
or if it's like there's just like these
weird [ __ ] barriers of entry
and then someone comes and supersedes
them and then they break the door down
and yeah
yeah yeah yeah but it's the other
problems
but they break the door down and then
they're followed and but the problem
i want it to be more scrappy i think i
just wanted a problem
in order for a woman to make it in
movies they got to be sexy so then it's
like you're
trading on asian sexiness and just all
the and guys got to be
sexy and they got to be athletic kind
mostly all super shallow it's all
incredibly shallow
then we go to race and gender yes it's
already a shallow [ __ ] thing
i think i just want the movement to be
like a proper movement
and scrappy and just like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
that
asian people have been blah blah this
has been going you know i i think that's
why i just want it more yeah in your
face and yeah it's
uh organized but it's
it's too it's [ __ ] nebula it's a
really
subtle thing and it it's subtle and
in the ether it's like
they're still like black people probably
got more violence against them
last week than asia just don't be
violent nobody be violent
and then you get into why are people so
violent america
i think it's capitalism if i had to
point a finger
i'm gonna bet capitalism and the
founding it's just [ __ ] that's
these that are too big even for this
podcast
wow which covers so hot for the pie
i love the issues you guys can't get our
arms around again
for the pot a special four-part
runoff um
uh covet in miami
looking hot you know this is where i go
people didn't change i can't why
why are you doing this to us we just got
we just got out i'm so
[ __ ] you miami anti-social that true
i i can't even i look at them like what
the [ __ ] i understand that that's what
most people are like
especially young people are like
throbbing to go outside yeah
um and they want to twerk and they they
want to get something i'll look at that
and they they want to they want to flex
uh
they want to they want to go this is
like a gallery of
like a art gallery release these photos
well photo photography as i've heard
mentioned on here before it's not
difficult um
and people another theory of mine that
people loved
um so yeah i don't
people young these are great photos
young people that aren't
that intelligent are dying to get out
they're just not that smart and they're
dying to get around
other smart people these people aren't
smart neil no the
those these poi they could be wait is
that
they're stanford they're all stanford
they're
it's two white women am fighting about
i don't think the lady on the left is
white what is she she's latino
she's italian italiano
um so i i i just don't
i'm not this is everything i didn't like
about the world photos are so
funny and it's everything i didn't like
about the world and i can't believe that
people
are racing back into it but it's just
this is what most of the countries like
it's i don't want to be in a
really crowded group for a while it's a
bunch of dim-witted people
trying to get together to form a decent
idea
they they all put in they all the 10th
of the brainpower
of a regular person and they all try to
join up
to have the brain power of one person
to form a voltron so they can move
forward and go
go down collins in miami
we got to go down college y'all um
so you know i
co still 55 000 same
same [ __ ] number as last week what if
seven days
what if this is a cool people sturgis
uh how many percent of those people do
you think
they're not i mean they're not cool how
many percentage of those young people do
you think
are vaccinated uh
well 30. they're you're not gonna
believe this they're stupid and they got
their doubts about they've done some
research about
the vaccine and they don't trust it
because they're so smart
i don't think i'm 30 would be highest 30
would be high okay
um but yeah just
your people are i just really don't want
people are notorious people will just
keep doing it
i'm now i'm to the point where i'm like
i just want california to be good
apparently california is going to be the
most good
did you do that article uh no but i know
all the trends are
like very very it says that california
is
going to fair that we're going to be
wuhan of
of america that's great i mean if you
look at that chart
don't come keep leaving it's like the
numbers are
like 2 700. what's that new cases
yesterday were 1900 in the state
like that's really good that's very very
good
i'm very proud of every single one of
you i'm gonna drive around tonight and
let people know i'm gonna be like asian
people get over here they're gonna be
like i get the [ __ ] and then they're
gonna
it's gonna be wild no i wanted to
congratulate you all
right oh it's about covenant he's
turning into this big man
every day they're gonna run they're
gonna go get
the gun that they keep in the in the
drop ceiling
um moving on bianca
kylie jenner okay this is i have a
question this is more about you
believe it or not so finally something
about me on this podcast
go ahead let me tell you a little story
so kylie jenner's
let's say makeup artist or somebody got
hit by a car
someone in her inner circle got hit by a
car or there's some
accident happening yeah and he had a 60
000
gofundme and she tweeted it and also
contributed five thousand dollars okay
so
what do you think when someone
do you know is in need of money like do
rich people like is it her
is it on her why she can afford sixty
thousand dollars and that's her friend
so why people would want to say if i had
the kind of money she has
i have the kind of money you can oh i
don't have the kind of money she's got
like 800 million dollars she has less
than that remember they came in
right 500. by the way the fact that
kanye
is the richest black man alive it's so
funny made me laugh
for 10 seconds yesterday yeah i don't
even know what to do it doesn't mean
anything
it's just multipliers it's so funny i
know but it's just so
[ __ ] funny i can't even it's like
okay cool um
so what is your idea of what's my
ceiling
no just okay a one what's your ceiling
two what is
just because you're rich do you have a
weird obligation to spend money
in kind of like not like
not dumb i mean that's helping us no i
don't think it's but i know what you
mean like if you got
income like this there are times where i
will like know i'm getting money i'm
like i guess i should buy something
do you penny pinch
i [ __ ] pinch okay is that is now the
time to talk about it
okay um no i meant
i don't even know what it is but i love
the term
you don't know what it is oh
it's a great time for example uh
uh i don't i don't wanna ask people
questions
uh yeah i don't 60k is that is that kind
of a lie
if somebody if i if i had the kind of
money she had
60k wouldn't move i of course
you had the kind of money you have if i
had the kind of money i had and
somebody bijan needed 60 grand
for a medical thing i it would there be
i it would be done and it's i it would i
would take care of what about will
that's tough
that's where you get into like being
i've known for 20
i don't know almost 20 years you know
edited spell show it like my brother
yeah will my bucket
will a nice kid that i like that has
worked with me once a week for a year
no one cares about it so 60. we're going
to edit this out
you hate to put a price tag will's dying
neal 60 would be like
whoo 60 i'd be like i have to get up and
walk around a little bit
go sit on a pier wow would 60 be like
here's 60 but like
i don't kind of want to ever see you
again
like do you want to give money and just
be like yeah
no here's what i hear i got i
said there was a there's a guy i know
who
i once he's a he's a cocaine user
because it's relevant to the story i'm
not going to tell you who it is
no i just the way um he's a cocaine user
uh and he smells of drink uh he's a
cocaine user sits in the parlor and
he i had to lend him money one time give
him money for rent one did you know he
was a cocaine user prior
i got this sense and but i've known him
so long that he needed
rent money i gave him some rent money
wow is he successful
i'm gonna keep this as vague as i can oh
okay
uh and but it wasn't it was 600 bucks
it wasn't like an ungodly amount of
money but it's you know no it's
600 bucks is like not nothing yeah it
doesn't matter how much money you have
it's never about the at a certain point
it's like i'm you're not going to
punk me you're i'm just not i'm just not
going to be made to look like a [ __ ]
i'm
like that's what it comes down to with
any interaction
with the richest or the poorest it's
like don't insult me
so then he needed money
for a medical thing oh and
this was like into the five grand
neighborhood
and i gave him the money
and he kept going on and on about
gratitude and did it but it was like
there was just something about it it's
like
you shouldn't keep asking me for money
yeah like
this is [ __ ] up and i didn't say that
i just was it twice
well he asked me for the rent money and
then a year and a half later
there was no payback for the rat um if
okay if he paid back the rent would you
be a little like yes if you pay back the
rent cool
thank you like for instance the amount
of people
dave one time gave me a thousand dollars
to move out here
i'm his accountant said i'm the only
person that's ever paid him back
for anything and he's 47.
wow like people don't pay if they think
you have money they
they're like that's why i love that um
oh [ __ ] who has that joke was it
hey chris chris chris is joking
what's the joke no sorry uh how
i think chris said like all of them
would go out with will and then one day
will didn't eat anything and they had
bought they just racked up a bill
thinking
with will smith yeah wasn't that the job
i don't think i don't know the story but
that
is funny and then he didn't eat me he
just got there late
and then didn't eat yeah and then when
the bill came they were like [ __ ]
i was gonna pay for this [ __ ] yeah which
i don't i
dinner is a different thing no of course
there's like different laws
but so i said to the guy i was like just
stop it with the long
texts wait so what would you preferred
him to do uh
can i get him to pay me back the rent
money
and then it's because my brain can just
go
into this is money he should be able to
pay this
but because he threw it just was using
coke all the time
now it's kind of my problem yeah and
that's where i was like
ah don't and then he got mad at me
for like what would he be mad at you
because as i said to
somebody yesterday there's nobody more
justified
than uh cheater meaning
like how dare you how dare you it's like
the equation
it's like yeah no cheaters ever cheated
because they're a piece of [ __ ]
people cheat because i i well she he did
such and uh furthermore it's like uh
quavo
and sweetie broke up and she said uh he
stepped out with another woman
if you give your self to somebody else
like you're not and he was like
you weren't the woman i thought you were
to do this to me
take care and everyone's like so you're
mad at her because she put your horse
no no you if somebody that you're
friends with is treating you badly
they're probably [ __ ] your spouse
girlfriend or boyfriend
i i sw it's it's like it's an immutable
look it's an immutable human law no one
will treat you worse than someone who's
[ __ ] you in some other way
because then they're just mad at
themselves that yes they're just all
spun up so if somebody if
if you're on my list
it's it's taken care of and i'm not that
rich like i'm
doing all right but i'm not like i
uh what uh
a very rich person who was on a sitcom
told me one time
that somebody asked him how much money
he had and he goes
i have so much money that once a week
a guy comes to my house to tell me how
much money i have and by the end of the
day i've forgotten how much money
it's a lot of money i don't have that
kind of money um okay so
do you think so this is reprehensible
okay
it's reprehensible just old-fashioned
reprehensible just
exploitive of fans and
just reprehensible how just in no way
defensible to me
it you guys want some sort of fame
notoriety you know
rich people that have made their money
entertainment now that sounds
loaded it doesn't i'm just getting
through the setup
at what point is your money everyone's
business
because it is it's kind of our business
now it's like well you're a billionaire
you wanted to be a billionaire you're
you're proud of being a
self-made billionaire so hello
well i yeah i that's that's an argument
i don't
i just think the best argument is the
thing i say to chris
i was like we have a bunch of fries
people can see the fries
right give them a [ __ ] fry
that's so so people really can see her
fries
yeah really i mean you can see them they
can
you can really see kimmy's they can pick
these fries you can really you can pinch
them
um but yeah
fried pensions uh
french fry pencils um so
yeah so it's irreprehensible pay it shut
the [ __ ] up
okay pay it and and i never need to hear
about it okay
yeah like you shouldn't don't take
credit just pay it
oh on gofundme do you do anonymous i do
not
oh wait do i do anonymous yes and there
was
recently uh i i thought you were going
there do i leave my name
i said and that's oh you do anonymous i
do an honest yeah
um the recent one wait i think we all
yeah the recent one yeah
somebody said my name is like you did hi
but the problem is it wasn't as much as
yours
no i know but i it was funny to see who
put their name
well i feel like okay it's again
but you know what the argument is if a
celebrity puts their name
to a charity the charity gets more
donations
yeah so that's the that's like the kind
of the
my argument for putting your name uh
i was talking to annie leaderman about
it and she was like
you only put your name if it's really
low or really high
in the middle like [ __ ] i was like
why no i don't think
really low like i don't have a lot of
money i don't have molly money but like
hey man yeah gesture wise and really
high to be like
yeah giving you five thousand dollars
yeah you're gonna know one name
everyone's gonna know like do you look
at it like
you want you know what's funny this is
like a kirby enthusiast
but like i gave i remember giving money
to somebody a long time ago
uh like on a gofundme and uh and i gotta
say i've never
really liked his tone since i've seen
him wait what do you mean
just not the level of gratitude wait
that's like kevin's joke about
when he gets a he tips really big to a
waitress and they're like thanks
yeah and he's like no you like he
tipping
yeah yeah that's exactly i'm always i
when people tip me they
like the big one that was you didn't
need to do that and you still did it
thank you so much that is heart that is
so kind of you and you didn't need to do
that
yeah i don't i just it should just be
like some
but like hey neil no just like give me a
like some recognition that i gave you a
decent amount of money
because i that i didn't really know you
well
neil just to use your own advice if
someone is
treating you a little funny he might
he's [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] linda
that was my girlfriend at the time linda
this is in 1977.
uh my name was was buck and she was
linda
uh alexa mccammond
teen vogue you're not going to believe
it
what happened you know
we're dancing this is such a good this
is close
to those close captions let's describe
what we're doing
i do give a glitch uh alex mccammon
is the woman who is half black
had the tweet she's 27. asian
bad week for her to those tweets again
right yes well that's another
it's like but we're fine so let me get
this straight
this week we're fine with
harming black women in a professional
setting
well you can't make that about race it
was just about a tweet
okay i mean that's that i could apply
that to a lot of [ __ ] that it's like
well it's not about race just
any anyone would but the thing with race
is
you're if in the woke culture
black women have more points
than right you know what i mean like
they didn't apply the point system
somehow
right um so
she so she that we talked about last
week she
had tweets from high school literally
17. i already apologize for that i
apologize for them in 2019 ago
and then apollo and then gets the job at
teen vogue
a a a unequivocally
great job right 27 especially like
outstanding and the 20
10 to 20 members of the staff signed a
petition
saying that they couldn't work under her
under any circumstances now here's the
as i said to you over text the
great writing surprising the sound of
great writing is surprising
but inevitable here it is gang one of
the women
on the petition had her own
tweets with the n-word in it
what the [ __ ] no one could have seen
this coming well you need it
um no one could have seen this coming uh
except anyone who's been alive for
more than 25 years um not me
uh so yes she tweeted the n word that
was 23 hours ago
wait go christina david christine davitt
yeah
tweeted racial slurs so i don't know
she's gonna have
i mean i would say if she had any honor
she would quit
but something tells her like the
departed of racist tweets
mutually assured destruction yeah it's
why nuclear
bombs work right it's because we all
know if we start one of us start yeah
literally with guns yes um
uh
yes she was an asian staffer white white
and asian
and uh she still has a job apparently
that's as of today that's as of
yesterday
once right they can't hold on they're
not gonna because if they hold on to her
then alex mccain can sue them for
a zillion dollars yeah uh hopefully she
will anyway
um but this is my my question
to everybody how are we gonna do this
how are we gonna do this going forward
because there's no it's like i would say
nothing no apologies good enough and
also they're all full of [ __ ] any time
someone is pointing the finger
when you destroy your dish yourself
uh you just it's there's no it's just
it's it's it's so [ __ ] hacky at this
point
that it's just endless what do we do
what do we do we
say like
i don't know can we just like as a
national just purge day
everyone well no because then the people
amnesty you have to
i don't mind it for some and then white
people are like you
dirty [ __ ] that's the thing so
it doesn't work
when your tweets are against me yeah
i only am empathetic
through your group not me i represent
everybody one well this she's a black
girl she's doing her thing okay she only
said
asian she didn't say anything
technically derogatory so that's what
four billion people it could have been
anybody
couldn't have been talking about
russians probably was if i know alexi
like i think i do that's the
that's the problem is we all are too
sympathetic to our own and
too outraged when it's against us so how
do you it's there's a phrase
get ready for old man phrases give me a
quick one
[Music]
uh
[Music]
defense attorney for yourself prosecutor
against everyone else
did you feel that you guys defense
attorney for yourself
prosecutor against anyone else
so like yeah so you we can keep this up
but corporations shirt gonna start
getting sued i mean like it's
there's gonna have to be some like
but how what like that's bad both of
them are not both of them
bad in different like not in different
ways but just
no none of them are good none of them
are like well that one's that one's not
bad like it's like they're both bad so
what
dude they apologize like if someone
apologizes i mean
the joke is they would have been better
off murdering people because people want
criminal justice reform that's the
problem so
they don't want social media justice
reform they
criminal but you but we're going to take
all of the vindictive energy
all that like weird christian
pentecostal
[ __ ] and aim it at these new criminals
i know there's a book i don't i'll bring
you up next time because
i don't i don't remember enough right
the second to like quote and stuff but
it's basically about stopped
i'm gonna paraphrase the [ __ ] out of it
but it's basically
my friend's reading it and he said it's
really interesting it makes the argument
that
um you can't
be in favor of favor of you know
quote-unquote cancel culture
or this kind of [ __ ] you can't be about
this and also about
um jess's reform for black people it
doesn't work because of course but
yeah but in it but it's it's from what
he
he was telling me and like i kind of
read an excerpt it's really interesting
i'm gonna
get all the info next time but the
argument is so
it's like what do you want what hurts
people
i don't know like but it's because
people
it's this regional thing it's a regional
thing
meaning we're having conversations and
meanwhile it's like
it's a jerk-off effect because no
almost no legislation gets changed as a
result of it of course and
uh so it's i they people go
that's what i want be they because
part of being woke is uh
wanting to fight for oppressed groups
then you go well black and latino
are oppressed groups and they're
over-incarcerated
so i'm going to be for that but then if
one of them does something
racist against an asian person then
you're like oh [ __ ]
like the with the lexi mccabe it's like
[ __ ]
i wish you weren't black right um it'd
be easier if she was every way
no one would be like another one bites
at us
moving on uh but it
people don't understand the
contradiction or they don't they do
but they do but one is hotter literally
one's culturally hotter
being for criminal justice reform is hot
and so is being so is woe culture the
problem is
also that when something is offensive to
you
you know your first instinct is [ __ ]
that
it's not you know what let me chill
let's see let's give it some due process
and see what
really is going on it's just kind of
well
i mean when i see racist people on
videos i'm not i'm like yeah get them
you know yeah i mean all like this is
another thing
try to not do it no for sure i'm not
saying like you in particular
i know the same thing it's all about
temperance in a weird way like
temperance
not in the christian way but like in the
just like
increasing the distance between
reaction response like that's the that's
buddhism and whatever but like
like yes i want to [ __ ] ah it's like
somebody who doesn't look like me but
then you just like okay but we're not
doing that at all i mean you do
like for example twitter karate you know
that
like it all comes from the same like
i am going to like strike back
yeah i don't strike no no no no no no
but like
the video comes out it's a old white
lady saying you [ __ ]
yeah no one's like wait you guys
hold on maybe she would you know there's
it's hard
to well it's hard but there's so much
such a premium put on
the emotion of like yeah the
condemnation emotion
that it's which is like what's the
difference between
getting mad at that lady and getting mad
at the [ __ ]
in 1810 like what's the
it's the same mechanism oh it's the
scarlet letter the [ __ ]
walk the plank walk the town square
barracks [ __ ] you know the problem is
in the stocks right i think that we
should just do the stocks
meaning that thing where they would put
yeah put alex and mccain in the stocks
for two days
but you still have that stock dust on
you
no you don't because everyone will go
everyone will have gone
it just becomes like oh everyone gets
their seats
you're all we're all gonna get it
eventually i'll get it for my asian
jokes and get it for the
i mean like i'm going for it like a year
so don't you got to find another thing
to make money
no um so yeah like
if we all just do something
that is humiliated like a dunk something
because this is
unsustainable it's sustainable for dumb
[Music]
hungry people that like get off on it
but
it's not as of culture it's not
sustainable
yeah and it's not and it's not we can't
take it
um longest podcast i've ever been on
i've never done rogue in five times um
vanessa bryant kind of we don't need to
talk about it she won the lawsuit and
then in the no in the lawsuit she
the names of the cops are in it was like
okay
um should we just read them out loud
yeah i don't care
um again why be vindictive
i mean isn't that the point didn't you
want them that's what she wanted she's
not a moral arbiter
right that's what she wanted what i'm
saying
why are you yelling what i'm saying is
you're like well isn't that what you
wanted we should read the names
yeah but no no i'm not saying let's do
her bidding i'm just saying
the point was to that everybody knows
these lapd officers that did this thing
yeah
okay that way i'm knocking i already
forgot him i'm looking at him right now
and i'm already
you wrote that on there and you know i
don't know what's going on no i was just
bro trying to blow through it okay but
you wouldn't let me blow it okay now you
blew it um
i i'm out here please adventure um
okay now massage another massage story
this week
desean watson 12 sexual misconduct
things
in massage things in uh from personal
uh which is
there's a few things in my mind here uh
which is thinking that
every girl wants to [ __ ] you well did he
go to
massage parlor because no these are
regular masseuses i believe
my guess is he got one of them to do it
13 separate cases against him
and i think it's a case of he wants
every he thinks everything okay okay he
didn't get it he didn't
yeah inappropriately acting
appropriately after hiring a female to
give him a private massage
uh what you should do buddy is find
one also not hard to find
uh that situation i feel like someone
would know
somebody sure uh
yeah i would think um
so so yes what's going on with the
agency
she demanded or he she oiled his anus
several times
oh well that's just homophobia like
that where is anus no no i'm just
wondering what's
the [ __ ] for like that's just someone
read
i'm saying what i'm saying is the person
who wrote this
just wants it to be like he wanted his
anus oil he's already
got sexual assault beefs with 13 of them
the anus oiling
is shouldn't even be a thing i was just
looking at it because
if you hire someone to do a private
massage and they think they're just
doing a massage
and also someone says like who gets them
step one they start i'm just saying that
i'm putting myself in her position just
like
when i go and soothe i go must
start at anus and work out clearly we'll
see what happens
and we'll quote see what happens okay
hashtag
different rules yeah [ __ ] picture
um just with
deshaun watson uh i i don't know what to
tell these guys
tell them something just don't don't do
it just find one
person or something i don't know uh
write a book chauvin trial
oh he wanted it moved we talked about
this last week right
no we just talked about the jury oh wait
did we no i didn't yeah
they moved to outer space oh no they
didn't move it he got denied
it has to be in middle honor it's back
on earth it's back on earth and i it's
the first time i've
actually seen a cop trial not moved
they didn't allow them to delay it and
they didn't allow them to move it out of
minneapolis
great usually doesn't ever happen great
yep
yes sir uh so
good for i mean good for you know uh
making a bad situation maybe a little
better
that's a good part not exactly a victory
but it's a good one
what's a romantic aromantic is that the
thing i sent you the thing
so i found a subreddit this week gang
uh it's the subreddits aromantic so the
letter a
and romantic um now what is it
it is asexual
but about romance so is that you so it's
i
no it's not me but i'll tell you what
i it made me feel better
because i've been i ha i had a thought
or
i haven't made it a joke yet but they
have a flag
oh my god a romantic
flag is so terrible
it's official it's a it's the the the
android
bubble green and then a lighter version
of that a white stripe a gray and a
black
not a bad not a bad that's a terrible
flag well it could use a little
definition
it needs another element um
so aromanticism
is like asexuality like i'm not i don't
wanna i don't don't wanna have sex with
people
aromanticism is i don't wanna date
people
i and you but they want to [ __ ]
yeah they're not squares okay no yeah
they want to [ __ ]
so it's what i hasten to say is
guys let's not abuse this this is like
this could be the sex addiction where i
think i'm a sex addict
i'm aromantic right this is what neil's
the definition is
aromantic people are not necessarily
incapable of feeling love
uh but they they
they just don't feel romantic attraction
to people
uh they may feel a familial love a type
of platonic love
that's expressed between friends podcast
hosts
individuals who identify as aromantic
may have trouble distinguishing the
affection of family and friends
from that of a romantic partner never
been a problem for me
um i can tell my sister
from some abroad from
instagram um and yes broad is the right
term
uh many aromantic people are asexual but
the term aromantic can be used in
relation to various sexual identities
such as aromantic bisexual abram
whatever but this is the thing that
excited
me about this was that there are
so many sexual orientations and there's
like
one relationship orientation which is
you gotta
you gotta settle down you gotta commit
you gotta settle down
and you go right like open and yeah
what about the polyamory sexual
okay like that's what i'm saying there's
so many sexual orientations poly
by uh a multiple multiplier
i don't know gangster okay bbc
gangbang have a flag yeah uh you don't
want to see the gang
trust me um so it was exciting to me
that
this exists i don't feel uh this is not
me
but and i don't feel seen but i feel
looked at
in the direction of because it's uh
the idea that you don't have to
constantly be moving toward this
uh stable committed relationship that's
one way the only way of doing a
relationship like you're not even really
allowed to sleep in separate beds
people do but other people don't like it
yeah it's weird
they don't like it the only i said i've
always said this the only way i would
ever live with a guy is if i had my own
bedroom like we got to get a two bedroom
yeah whose idea was it to compromise
comfort in space so that we're in one
room
i don't want to share a bathroom with a
[ __ ] guy
do you know what i mean yeah sure my
bathroom's not bad it's a little cool
your bathroom's pretty good
when you've lived with a girl do you
send her downstairs bathroom
no do you please do you want to watch
watch i want to watch it clean it again
um yes so this was exciting to me this
is great
it's just it's it's a it's a 30 000
member
subreddit it's not a it's not a
blockbuster
um but um
wait so it's what's all a romantic it's
it's uh
a romantic go up
a no the r slash it's like a-l-l or
romantic oh well it's another term i
guess
aloe romantic i don't know what the [ __ ]
that means um i'm new to
this lifestyle alloromantics
it's describes the opposite of a
romantic opposite of aromantic
a person who experiences romantic
attraction a romantic desire and a clear
consistent frequent enough manner to
uh no relationship to the area okay so
this is one of these terms that is so
unnecessary
like guys you didn't need this you're
[ __ ]
ruining the whole thing with [ __ ]
useless terms because everyone else i
need a term
i'm a sis aloe romanta shut the [ __ ] up
anyhow when i um i learned a lot when i
took psychology in college now i started
realizing
guys too many terms for things too many
terms there's a term for
every single thing we do as humans yeah
that's to quote the great philosopher
dave chabelle white people got too many
words for [ __ ]
true death um
so oh this is this is getting deep
demi-romantic
yeah they're useless it's useless just
romantic and aromatic that's all we need
okay that's all we need okay
don't even look okay um
so just to know that this is available
even though it's a small community
something about that thing of that push
toward
i wouldn't will a romantic person write
us i want to yeah i hope i wonder i bet
we have a few
a romantic holler a romanticist and i
hope that
um yeah it's just it's
the way people frame their lives also
it's like
i'm gonna how about
anything how about you and him
[Music]
are you gonna [ __ ] i that's not my
[ __ ] bag lady
um anyhow so that's a romantic look it
up
um doc watch
i only date women who do their own taxes
if you're sitting
here it is incredibly stupid it's
so funny um before we start talking
watch i guess it's a dock watch nate
bargatzi
has a uh special out and
[Music]
it's the greatest average american on
netflix and it's
he shot it in at universal studios in a
parking lot
that they made to sort of look like a
comedy club
and i thought it was great it was like i
did see the
it was the i liked it better than his
last one not by a lot but like it
by nose and uh it also
he was like there was funny because like
helicopters come by and he's like
[ __ ]
all right here's another helicopter uh
but it kind of proved the point of like
venue doesn't really matter like i don't
once
you're telling me the joke i'm not like
it's just deliver the joke venue matters
more
to you than it does the audience i think
yeah i don't and venue matters more to
me because it's
money and i just mean the comics
and also some like everyone like the or
you can't recreate the or anywhere
if you can kill noah you're good like
people stop by the or to work out their
[ __ ]
right because there's some i don't know
yeah that's
the venue is important it like makes a
difference to us but what i'm saying is
just is this joke good right what's the
joke i don't care
about the the [ __ ] pills
like oh look at the pillars there's
times where i'll like when i'm direct i
remember me and bijan who
16 60
we were editing seth's special seth
meyer special
and i was like there's just at the
beginning there's like a cut to like a
[ __ ] pillar and i'm like boy that's
useless it's in there
but it doesn't mean any it literally
means nothing what's your
it's there's the side side wide what's
the one you hate the most what is it
the you there was one you went off
like i hate that angle and that cut in a
the cut away to the crowd no laughing
maybe it was
or maybe the perspective of like wait
was it from the side
no it's well there's one yeah there was
some
there's one from behind behind the comic
that you use for editing but some guy
i won't say what this scenario but a guy
you know
like put it in a cut like
not to cover it like just like it's a
cool venue and i like this shot for me
no and and i said uh you guys i saw
craig the guy's name saw craig at a
party last week and somebody was telling
a story
and craig was uh bending down behind
them
to hear it from the best angle that's
the best angle to hear a story
is on your knees behind the person
looking at their back
because i'm a petty person i did it on a
groupie anyhow
anywho this woody allen documentary
finished up
and uh and i believe him no i'm kidding
um it's just
not good i mean just uh bad
and and uh
woody allen molested uh dylan i think
and i think uh people didn't care he did
it
and i think i
liked a lot of his movies after it and
christina barcelona victor christina
barcelona is a [ __ ] masterpiece
bullets over broadway's a
borderline masterpiece match point
[ __ ] really good
match point's really good um
but vicky virginia's vicky christina
barcelona is the one
it's this this scene with javier
broaddam in the hotel
room in the hotel lobbies it's this
night just bawl me
um do
you feel like you can keep
re-watch [ __ ] from him
what's interesting is knowing what i
know
about a lot of these people
i'm already watching it with
by knowing the secret that the audience
doesn't know a lot of times like
so-and-so's an [ __ ] so whatever so
i'm watching it
more i'm not like rushing to watch a
woody allen movie
right but and i and
i'm not gonna give him any more money if
i own annie hall am i still allowed to
watch it
i i don't know who gets hurt if i watch
it right um
i don't even think dylan would get hurt
so that she's the only one i answer to
uh so i don't know like i don't i'm
already
i don't think i didn't i never i've
never watched a
work of art thinking that the person's
child molester
i i pro i mean no rush too i may never
watch another woody allen movie
yeah but [ __ ]
that guy's really talented
that's all i'll say about that how about
how does it how does it make how do you
feel about it
um i haven't watched the
the last two or the last two so i don't
it's like ian edwards joke where it's
like well then you still can't you still
enjoy them while you're right
ian's like yeah don't tell the joke no i
won't tell the joke but i just whenever
he says i'm like
yeah that actually is more more people
do that than
we think the j i'll say the joke the
facts
okay all right the
i get it like it's uh it's it's
just like dark and some you know after
mother aya i
have to uh ration
the darkness i love i love a good light
i love light um
light yeah um and this is someone who
used to go to sleep to unsolved mystery
robert stack and would wake up in a
fright
too you would cover your bed in blood
and then and then lay down on it
you'd put a gun and a knife rope and
you'd be like all right i think i'm
ready to i'm ready to hit the hay
um so i just like it's really hard for
me to do dark dark
yeah i uh i can't do it i
fall asleep it's a great [ __ ] break off
correct documentary fall asleep the
graveyard is bigger bless
boom blessings i have to and i'm
actually nice
i i like hearing i almost feel like i
watched it i'm like okay cool yeah it's
more it's just
more evidence how do you feel about
because i still am like
ah mia what the [ __ ]
she says at one point like it's the
biggest regret of my life bringing them
into
our lives okay good you know
that's about all you can ask for yeah um
and
there's this stuff of like who's is it
journalism all that stuff it's sort of
i just gave up on that yeah just like i
just watch it for what it is
and speaking of stylistic choices dude
the operation varsity blues is it called
operation varsity
no it's called it's called the colleges
when it first started i
as soon as it said reenactments i was
like i'm out
there it's mostly reenactments it's more
a narrative movie i mean
it it they got then they got
matthew modine a guy from the 80s
uh this is how white the 80s were
matthew mundine was in a competitive
sailing movie
wow uh look that up will matthew modine
sailing and it was called
wind wind wind
uh matthew modine sailing anyhow
but didn't we have it we really had we
didn't know how good we had it white
people
um carol ballard directed it wait i'll
give you a i'll give you
60 grand if she's black um
wait how long did the movie do it ain't
do good uh people
there wasn't much of an appetite 96 000
in australia and if you don't if you
can't work in australia
if you can't work a sailing movie in
australia you're in real trouble too
good
50 of rotten tomatoes anyhow matthew
modine played the guy
played the guy you gotta have a lot of
footage to do these movies you can't
that was it was yeah i enjoy i
i cause chris smith that guy did the
fire festival he's a very good filmmaker
the form the layout of how they
storyboarded it
i loved it i loved that everything was
real all the all the conversations were
wiretapped yeah but i wonder if there
was
it's basically a different way
i don't think there is because it
reminded me and this is no shade to the
because it was good and i watched the
whole thing
but it reminded me of a really
high quality lifetime movie yeah like
that well that's the
that the color tone was lifetime
yeah but the the difference was this
speaks to one of my beefs they do a
thing
because cameras camera sensors are
way better than they've ever been so you
can
shoot
good quality in low light yeah
so they did that here where everything
was backlit
it was so the every set is gray
and every lighting sources is
backlit every it's a and there's a
window behind everybody so you
you don't have to strength squint to see
the people but
i don't like that style i just don't it
like it doesn't it
i told somebody it feels like clinical
depression it feels like a like a
a commercial like it's in baltimore
zimbabwe
yeah like a little crawling sad bubble
um
so but i liked it
i liked the storyline of his great i
just you know the problem is okay
so let's take out reenactments some
people use
the i don't always love animated either
i don't mind animating if it's too i
think
the animation has to be good it has to
be good and it has to be appropriate as
well
um i don't know
i think they could have used more
i don't know it didn't no one cooperated
that's the problem the fbi guy like
there's
five it's like three fbi people
and then a couple athletic department
people
that's the list like no one's dying to
go like yes
what time i'll be there at 10 like no
one's dying to do that interview
because there's nothing to i mean not
only just nothing to gain
a lot of it's still pending a lot of it
was still pending they didn't have
sentences
um yeah but i i like
i like a i like a swing like that
but okay so just for the documentary
itself i
what was your takeaway what is your
uh i think college is the dumb one of
the dumbest things in the world
it's a it's a step i mean i have a new
college bit and i
i said to rock i was like i can i just
do another bit about how dumb colleges
yeah
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it like i'm like so my
act's just gonna be here's my update on
college
women i just talk about 10 things and
whatever um it's just
uh a racket just a racket
and you in order to get advancing life
they i
understand why the parents do it
like i understood why they cheated yeah
because you know
because their egos aside
okay i know a friend of mine who
told me one time he got into harvard
early admission and he said and i've
never tried hard again at school ever
and he's successful and what do you mean
after
after he got into harvard he didn't even
try out harvard
you don't have to you don't really have
to yeah the people no one goes what
harvard let's get the transcript shall
we that's the funny thing
no one gives a [ __ ] about your gpa once
you're in college i
said to somebody if i if a kid i would
be more likely to hire a kid
if he said i went to
uh cal state northridge
and because i think that college is a
racket
and paying for college is a sign of
stupidity
and not intelligence and hopefully i
can say this way i can save money and
have a better life
be like i'm so much more apt to hire you
than i am
a guy who went to harvard right because
that you're an original thinker
you've you actually saw it for what you
could distill what it was
ahead of time and had the bravery to be
like
i'm not doing this it was weird i
applied to
usc in a state school and i got into
both that
i'm confused you got into usa yeah i
don't understand why they thought it was
that hard
they were like begging me i think it is
hard
by the way we've talked about this
before the quad of usc
is one of the nicest places i've ever
been on earth
it's not like not for a college
it's the nicest loc it it's beautiful
it's it's stunning perfect you can't
it's like the perfect
it's heavenly green
it's it's a fl it's per it's a perfect
environment but you know it's funny my
friend came with me to the orientation
and she said you look great on this
campus like that what the [ __ ]
what do you mean everything looks great
that's how you pick this is i'm like
everything
everything wear your hair up it works
better on this campus
so i wanted to study international
business
and they didn't have a good
i didn't like the program so when i was
talking to the admissions counsel or
whatever
the person that helps you decide and i
said yeah you guys don't go abroad
though
like how am i supposed to study
international business if
there's no push to go abroad and he's
like well we only go we're our only
partnership is with
this school in denmark i was like i'm
not
you can say it however you want it's not
enough i'm like i'm not
studying danish yeah and he
said well if we don't have a partnership
with them
they're probably not good enough
to be like they're probably not at a usc
level yeah so you're like sort of one
school of economics
no and i was like no and i was like
that's kind of
ethnocentric i'm like don't you think
that sounds like a century
um i said don't you think it's
anthocentric for an international
business school
and he was like he gave me like he
sounded like a if you don't know
baby like this is ufc baby i was like
god jesus so i went to state school
which was
so much cheaper you saved 70 grand for
somebody my school was 1600 a
semester yeah so you saved a hundred and
something
yeah i did i didn't forget you or your
mom or whatever i was like this place
it's not it's that other joke they don't
have better facts
i don't even understand why it's they
have a list of books
and then a different person to go no
this is what it means oh it doesn't mean
what i think of it
no but you know what's funny at my
school i went to if you didn't
study abroad and work abroad you didn't
graduate
if you didn't study and work abroad if
you just were like
i don't want to go abroad the point they
say on it like if you don't want to
learn
internationally you are not going to
graduate from an international program
and i said well that makes more sense
then i went to there and it was
and you've been and you've been laughing
all the way to the back ever since
douche stings me scheisse right um so
yeah i don't know when i was listening
to them dying to get in usc
like am i smart or are these people
stupid what's happening
i love that thing of um where
what's her name's daughter is talking
about jade nova whatever the [ __ ] her
name is
um the jade nova's where are they now
singer uh the girl
the the olivia olivia
um she's like the school's the [ __ ]
worst and then she does that thing of
like
you know it's a privilege and i've
started thinking of gen z and
millennials as uh televangelists
where it doesn't matter what their lives
off
camera are [ __ ] it doesn't even
matter they're so
corrupt but if they go like corrupt
you know yeah but like you know it's
it's a privilege
and i want all my parishioners to know
this is [ __ ] full of [ __ ] um it's the
funniest part is
uh in the documentary there's that the
reason why olivia jade the
um full house lady and massimo daughter
the reason why she gets taken down is
like from a meddling uh
student counselor she got she's in the
room
yeah she's doesn't [ __ ] work and then
they're like
that meddling [ __ ] so great it's so
funny that he wouldn't stop
yeah well he's all he gets he doesn't
get a case like this
but once a decade not gonna lie i was
very happy the black guy turned
he's like yeah his name is like
immediately
the black guy the he's the guy yeah when
as soon as they trapped him he's like
it's that guy oh yeah
i don't snitch on black people white
people i'm having a snitch on
uh bianca formula one drive to survive
is back
apparently it's three seasons what
has been going have been doing laps for
three seasons this is the third season
and so many laps it's
start at the beginning really don't i'm
telling you
i'm not saying it like it's work i'm
telling you like
it's a [ __ ] dessert buffet of
of like
relationship drama love it work drama
love it these guys have like two-year
contracts so they're
constantly switching teams hilarious
they'll quit the team
early in the season to go to an to
declare to go to another team the next
season
thinking that c that team's dope the
team they're on starts doing better
the uh it's [ __ ] it's like switching
lanes yes like [ __ ] so
there's that part of it and then it's an
action movie
interesting and everyone's miked so they
have i love the pit crew guy they've got
cameras on the pitch
they're like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] guys no you
[ __ ]
and then they'll be like we have to tell
them something box box box box
box means come back to the pit oh
and uh it's [ __ ] great and and
so they're all miked there's crashes
there's
rivalries the funny part is lewis
hamilton
is so much better than everybody that
they barely cover them
i have a question it's driving and they
all have the same high performance
vehicles not one person isn't out doing
the others
you'll find out about that it's there
are like mercedes lewis hamilton's team
is just better than ever like that they
just have a better car
this this season he did some [ __ ] with
the steering wheel
that nobody saw coming wow this is the
world i live in this is there
is your great british bake off i can't
say enough it's
so well shot okay because they've got
these guys are going 200 miles an hour
and they're like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] like this
camera's right here it's on the steering
wheel
uh how long does it take yeah but do
they stop
they can't just stop uh yeah they can i
mean they're very high power brakes
they can't stop probably that quickly
but
they have it's like the machine this is
a very highly tuned machine so it's like
the and likes ginger spice's husband's
one of the
group so i have a question do you have a
do you have a need for speed
driving wise um no
you're not like yeah let me get on zoom
i don't i like
i'd rather move i hate like bumper to
butt i would rather do
side streets just to keep them moving i
don't like just like
bombay bumpers no who the [ __ ] likes
that
well you've heard my theory that people
will people are so simple that they
won't go
on the sides the size is clear just
because i don't
i never heard of it what do you think's
gonna happen are you gonna be
there's gonna be [ __ ] sand people
like star wars in the trees where
they're [ __ ]
so get on the side street guys
will's email somebody i want to take
this [ __ ]
[Music]
hey neil and bianca lst ner nice voice
i'm gonna play armchair psychologist
here and say your habit of
interrupting people even people you
respect like chris rock
stems from being raised in an
excessively large family
where the only way you or your siblings
could get your needs met like getting
love or attention from your parents
was to basically blow each other out of
the way
so what bonkers talkers and inkers
thinkers
careful i was like what'd you say
and that is correct sir
if by the way i would love i would ha
this
the phone lines are open for any
armchair
psychology on either one of us yes come
on we love it we love
you guys look at that
look at us listen to us um yeah that's
true
i think i've said that on the show no he
said it
okay i've said it in life i'm sure how
about that
guys i'm with me all the time i get to
listen to this podcast in 24 hours
goodbye um here's a here's a hard letter
hi neil and bianca another great podcast
you guys just finished by discussing the
question of whether white and black
professors
of african or black studies um
uh it's an interesting debate and one
that touches my life personally but i
don't want to get into the details of
that
i love when people like okay then go
ahead good thing you brought it up
what does occur to me is the natural
extension of the logic that only persons
of african descent are qualified to
teach the subject
is there then an equivalent assumption
that only a white englishman is
qualified to teach shakespeare because
shakespeare was a white englishman
uh this would be considered an aberrant
view by most this is a complex issue
and i'm not ignorant to the nuances but
what it obscures is the value of
academic
expertise does one need to be a plant to
teach botany
i'm sure you can go on with them i
realize that there are other
considerations particularly in the
american culture which is concerned with
representation
it's important and ability it okay uh it
comes down to
the pervasive implication that white
people are not permitted to inside black
culture because of historical and even
ongoing wrongs
uh while this is an understandable
position it's an emotional
rather than logical one it is also
uh an unenforceable double standard as
is sadly the prohibition
on immature white teenagers who are sold
the n-word via popular music then told
they are forbidden to use it
wow this guy this guy's spit
he's he's really said something right
there
uh this i agree with all this
that's what i was saying it's like the
the when does it
it should be whoever's got the most
knowledge and
is the most charismatic and uh
teaching teacher the most teacherous
teacher yeah
but i don't know he wraps the whole
thing up now
but then but this business i think you
were less on his side when we
did it last time
[Music]
a black professor
no you because you said you made the
white professor the most qualified and
the black professor
like under-qualified whereas the
e-mailer said i was just saying if
they're both qualified which was more of
what
what was close to the email you're
saying it was just like this was the
only class left
yeah if they're more if they're if
i guess the question is how much if the
black
professor is 10 worse than the white
professor
do you still go with the black professor
it was 20
at what point you got i got to turn my
back ready i just yeah
you were talking about more like uh
integral knowledge from being black
talking about yeah yeah which
which that gets into the shakespeare
thing
of like should a british no because
shakespeare
is a long time ago right so we can all
we can all study you know i don't know
shakespeare or
what's the what are other kind of like
confucius or just different things that
we can all study doesn't matter who you
are right
um but being black
black american history like you're
surprisingly isn't
that different like there's similar
signs that were held up in the 60s now
do you know what i mean so there is more
of a
i don't know but i will say i would i
probably would prefer to take
shakespeare from a
english person
why no it's fun it's a funny bias of
course
of course but i think it's the same
thing it's the same thing as the black
thing
yes the you would admit that the british
one is
irrational whereas the black one seems
more restless no i'm saying
i'm applying the same logic to both i
have the like what do you mean
i think that the british one is like
funny because it's
so like what difference does it make of
course
where you you're you're i seem to be
arguing that black
a black professor will make a difference
i i'm not gonna argue that because i'm
not sure right
but i i'm saying if we're talking about
african-american studies
a lot of what applies historically
applies to today
and so if you're a black person then you
have an added
layer that a white person can't they can
they can't speak to in the same way they
can understand they can
understand fully but then you know a
black professor will have a
level that that the white person
understands maybe personal um examples
blah blah i'm just saying it
shakespeare it's like no i well then
it's [ __ ] it's just it's like it's
cuter
it's cute it's literally cuter your body
but at the same time
besides being cuter i have studied
shakespeare from an american person
and i think the way
they um explain the
wording of course i mean the words of
the words you can get the definition of
of shakespeare right you don't need to
be english to understand it but
it sounds more authentic when it a
british person is saying it because
that was a [ __ ] like but it's not
what do you mean it's not more authentic
it's not more authentic than me like are
you talking about the actors you're
talking about the teacher
oh no i'm just saying like when you hear
it in
uh british accent it feels like that's
probably what was going on
yeah i i there we it's it's it's a
longer discussion
it's not a longer session we don't need
to we're going off i'm going to text you
about it later okay please hey guys
thank you for the baby
all my friends and and when all my
friends
are i don't know black asian or mexican
no all my friends and went to school
with our
black asian and mexican is what the
sentence is oh i just did
it uh we grew up cracking jokes on each
other's ethnicities with impunity
because
we all had love for one another it was
all in fun and had no hate as a white
guy with an asian wife die no stereotype
uh whenever i say a joke like uh we
would say as kids when we were
hanging out smoking weed and
skateboarding my wife calls me racist
i hate the whole i can't be racist i'm
married to an asian or
i can't be racist all my best friends
are different ethnicities excuse
how can i convey to her that i'm not
racist it's just funny to make fun of
stereotypes mine included
i think you gotta you gotta have an
understanding i'm surprised that it got
to marriage
right so it feels like you should have
clarified this
would have been a hurdle to already she
married a racist
and sir you married a snowflake um
she married yeah i don't uh i think that
should be
i'm just surprised if you guys are just
now getting to this
yeah um but i also think a good way to
be
is like yeah i'm racist i'm a little
racist i try not to make
governing decisions about it but the
assumption is we're all racist
just try not to act on it but your first
thoughts get
maybe gonna be racist and then you go
okay don't do that
i like yeah that makes sense but in a
in a like and we've talked about it
before in a relationship
you're racist with each other way before
marriage so the fact that
he's trying to now explain to her that
he's not racist i feel like
i'm assuming it's ongoing i'm just
saying there's a
when you when you say jokes like that
you assume the other person is
catching with your like now having said
that
there are jokes i would do
with say a dave or chris
that i wouldn't do probably wouldn't do
with a better head
with a without yeah with a black
girlfriend
or a wife just because there's just
there's a guy
thing right of like like squishiness
yeah of like how how hard are we going
here
are we going all the way i also don't
think
a banter and talking [ __ ] and ball
busting is fun when the other person
is not yeah they don't like it it's like
i don't do it again i just go based on
her comfortability
it's also no fun if she's like you're
racist like dude that's not oh all right
well so how long are you gonna be about
two days
right i just think the
level is whoever where's the bar
i feel like with you and dave and chris
you have a very like
you guys can handle a lot of stuff you
have a high bar for it yeah we like it
spicy
like it's spicy like it's lizzy are you
crazy spice
like wine you're like thai old man
yeah like exactly like we have to bring
it to the store
in a in a in a a suitcase goodbye
um hey nailing binky i was talking to my
mom and she said something along the
lines of i'm lucky you kids were easy to
raise
i do have a couple regrets and ways i
wished i had parented differently
uh end quote i thought maybe she was
referring to the three of us having no
curfew consistently smoking weed all
throughout high school
and being allowed to bring our
boyfriend's girlfriends home to sleep
over
in our rooms from the jump no
that wasn't what she was saying she said
she had regrets that she didn't enforce
us she didn't enforce us saying no sir
or yes ma'am
wow were you brought up to say yes ma'am
no sir
is this something you would uh expect or
ask of your children
lastly is that something you will die
that will die with our generation
especially considering the topic role
of gender in 2021 uh note all three of
us
were are polite respectful and good with
adults i also don't think she even says
ma'am or
yes ma'am no sir so who knows where this
came from
love from an est uh refreshing
spotify at 7 pm for the new episode
feeler hey
that's a high level that's a high level
if you're hitting refresh at seven you
might be a redneck
um the are what it i
here's a thing i think about sometimes
like
i there are dumb things
enforcement things that kind of escape
me right now but
that my mom made us not made it but it
was just like that was
expected that i'm grateful for
like what uh please and thank you
i think we're big like
the amounts of thank yous i miss are
probably
like under 10 i think
um so
like there are things that i would
probably enforce in a kid
uh but ma'am and sir get
feels slavy it's like military southern
slavey
yeah yeah ma'am man sir
i have i never really address any of my
parents
i don't need my friend's parents i
address them by their last name
just their last name no like hey mrs
no no what's up williams okay uh
no like hey mrs bling came to blah blah
blah still
it depends but as a kid always oh i
would that's
no question i never did that you never
did it i mean i nev
i've never called my friend's
parents by their street name they're
government
yeah um no but you're also we're
different generations so when i felt
old-fashioned doing it it's not that
kids my age
would say their first name but i don't
know just
kind of be like hey you're not
not saying the name you know yeah hey
there's certain people who
it's like if they're a certain age
there's an age
difference yeah it just feels like i
should call you mrs or mister
right for sure but even now like
i don't know i just never i if i
i call if you're if it's a stranger
interaction i say sir
like sir sir you left yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yes and i say like they're under 30 i
might be like yo
or hey yo mr freeze and thank you
well yeah they dropped something that's
the thing
somebody dropped something yeah how the
last time i was at an airport
somebody dropped uh i want to say a
stuffed animal
going the other way they're going this
way i'm going this way and i
like so and i was like hey man
and then your little girl yo no it was
an adult
and they i don't know if it was like a
scarf it was like something that
not irreplaceable but you say not
insignificant you say
hey man yeah like don't say both those
words very
you don't define them well yeah hey man
yeah hey man yeah yeah so
that guy i yelled i was like hey and
then i
and then i got in that position where
i'm like
keep it moving i wasn't gonna i would
have had to grab it and
chase him which i wasn't getting ready
to turn around no
so you're just like oh well that's
that's for the airport
where he's like hey do you want a photo
okay i'm going did you see that one
no anyways this one um
but so it you aren't that polite
well no i i've brought up another
subject which is how how
hard should you fight for somebody else
who dropped something
if it was a ticket that was the subject
i was going with i don't know if that
wasn't clear
um that if it's a ticket
if it's something like import if someone
drops a passport i will chase them yeah
100
but if it's a [ __ ] stuffed animal or
a scarf or a hat i'm like eh
yeah i mean if people like at the store
people leave [ __ ] all the time
i unless you are in the i will do
a courtesy walk lobby outside
yeah there's a million people out there
so i'm like yeah i don't
i can't we have do you ever go like hey
i found this
like any sort of big announcement i
guess you can't yell because the show's
going on right
no i'll know i'll know who it comes from
because it's at a table
oh god you'll recognize the people if
it's just on the floor i'm like yeah
a card we have so many cards you can't
believe credit cards
you cannot believe the things people
leave behind you how many passports are
left
at the store eight probably 50.
how over how much a period of time
there's always you know
people come people leave i don't even
know what we do with them there's so
many passports
that's interesting like passports and
they're all
not american yeah of course i don't i've
never brought my passport to the store
well some people don't have this yeah i
guess people need it for now uh
i feel so i just every password i'm like
there's a story behind this person
how did they get home like what the hell
so i don't know people leave [ __ ] so
ah minimal effort sir
so sir we're yeah i'm a yes please i'm a
yes thank you
may i i'm not a mayor no that's weird
mother i say mother may i
even if it's like a waitress um yeah
what about if you have a
if you wanna if there's a confrontation
with a stranger but you still don't
want it to escalate my g i just say my g
over and over again
kill my g my g goodbye um
hey neil and bianca long time listener
first time emailer
my question has to do with the vaccine
conspiracy theories amongst california
liberals in this
instance my parents in the past few
months my mom white
late 50s has started to float the idea
that she had a bad feeling
about the vaccine and she doesn't trust
the vaccine because there aren't any
studies yet
and what the long-term effects of it
will be last week
she texted my boyfriend a link to a
vaccine conspiracy theory video
and said that her intuition is that the
vaccine is bad and that we shouldn't
take
she's basically like what should she do
uh
there is a line by the great philosopher
neil brennan that
uh our gut is wrong 80 of the time
so but it's pretty deep
into three mics why not give her the
some
materials is she not because she's now
on some like
nah nah i don't even acknowledge that
that's not even
real y'all literally you're a sheeple
you're still my son
but you is a full-blown sheeple um
i don't i don't [ __ ] know i i don't
know what how to help these people
i think you'd the funny thing is as time
goes on and more people get it
i mean i don't know is it important that
she gets the vaccine
if she like one day
a few people are just not gonna get it
right yeah
so at one point it's like gotta put this
we just gotta hope
we gotta hope first you know we also
have to hope that we get hurt i mean or
a form of hurt immunity right
so but god uh rest in peace and i will
i will pay up to sixty thousand dollars
for your mother's funeral
goodbye bianca i couldn't think of
anything clever for your name
sorry quick side night a quick side note
i'm only one degree of kevin bacon away
from you i live in ohio and work at the
hippie fine dining restaurant in yellow
springs
and a while ago got to know dave and
elaine for a while
uh even met his kids i believe the
restaurant is called the winds hey i
used to
get a nice take out there the wind does
this um since you've taken ayahuasca you
said
something about no longer being an
atheist i i know you grew up catholic
but pretty much nothing to do
but have pretty much nothing to do with
it anymore and i know that most people
aren't digging on christians right now
especially evangelicals
but i consider myself a liberal
christian i used to go to pentecostal
church in middle school and high school
yes they were crazy in spoken tongues
uh if you say the following words really
fast it sounds like you're speaking in
tongues
here give it a try he untied my bow tie
he stole my honda he didn't tell my boy
he sold my honda are you okay
bianca is having a seizure i'm 41 now
and i've distanced myself from the
evangelicals as much as possible i go to
lutheran church this is like
white people have too many religions
yeah i'm like we don't
need to explain these for me i don't
know them i don't even
i don't i don't no because i just went
to catholic school and then i
i would see the signs like this is a
pentecostal i have no [ __ ] idea
i know black people go to baptist church
i don't know the i couldn't tell you the
difference
um which is uh the closest you can get
to being catholic
while still being protestant and i also
dated rachel evans
i don't know what that is basically i'm
humming in hawaii i'll get to my
question
what do you feel about liberal
christians do you know any i believe in
god and jesus yada yada but i also
believe in equal rights blm
i'm pro-lbgtq legalized sweden shrooms i
hate trump and a sycophant
since you had a somewhat religious
experience in ayahuasca do you believe
when i said i've experienced god's
presence too
that last question is a very good
question because
the ayahuasca my
experience of religion my experience of
divinity
on ayahuasca is so clear and complete
that it makes me doubt the ones i've
seen
sorry what do you mean uh makes me doubt
someone speaking in tongues makes me
doubt the holy ghost makes me doubt
my no i never believe in them
and then the completion of my
ayahuasca experience meaning like it's
so
thorough complete top to bottom that i
doubt that stuff because when you do
that stuff you get status
in the church it's like a cool like she
[ __ ]
barber caught the holy ghost whatever oh
is it like
i caught the holy ghost so god loves me
i have a better relationship with god
than you do
sorry i know i went to my stepmom's
church she's filipino
and when i was a kid everyone was crying
and yeah the more everyone cried louder
yeah it becomes a human arms race the
uh the joke keeping up with jones is
whatever you want spider-man meme
whatever you need interesting um
i
super listener cat said
she's done ayahuasca the last two
weekends and
she said and i hope i'm not betraying
any compasses
she's like my faith hasn't changed one
bit
meaning she believed all the stuff she's
in ayahuasca she already believed it
i was was she religious before she grew
up religious but she was more
like private relationship
with a uh higher power
my i didn't so yeah so yeah that makes
sense
what i get from it it's so complete
i tend to think that most people are
i likened it to when you the first time
you smoke weed
you're like you feel it and everyone's
going i feel it
i feel and you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about
that's what i think most religion is
most people's experience with religion
which is kind of the fault of the chur
whatever it's like
peer pressure shakedown there's just a
lot of reasons to have a fake
big experience at church yeah um
so to answer your question if you're
telling me
that you've experienced god's presence i
can't argue with you
and i have less doubt than i've had in
the past
once you i mean after ayahuasca
you start you know with people like oh
do you i'm like yeah
and but i'm like it has nothing to do
every religion has gotten it wrong
f1 i think i said on here everything's
such a big
thing which is i believe religion is a
perversion of ayahuasca
that's how much i believe in iowa it's
not even believe it's like that's how
uh profound the thing is because i
also believe people would behave
differently
if they if they the again it's
promo but it's such a
complete profound experience that you
you want to behave differently
you do you don't want to you do you do i
no
not want to i miss my late nights
watching negative things
yeah but it's like that's not good it's
just not for you
it's not for me it's just like things
that doesn't feel good in my body
just no there's a lot of things that i
don't
do anymore that i can identify as not
good
for whatever and but i bet you found
yourself
being either not doing them doing the
months and being a little repulsed by
them
without even thinking about it like
muscle memory do it and then like
you know like the mood for this for the
next
six months i don't like my spooky my
spooky stuff
yeah it just doesn't hit the same and
it's weird for me
because it was this is a part of me a
little bit
yeah and i don't i don't like the spooky
i don't like negative i don't like um
i i've never really been into it but i
don't like
negative gossip something about like
really just like hardcore venting about
someone
with no solution or no plan like call to
action no like
plan of like hey what are we gonna do
about this i get really
i can go one step further which is i was
gasping the other night and i got
nauseous
yeah no i don't like gossip and i love
gossip
right like i'm it's i don't want to sell
myself as like i'm
this pious person i like gossip still
but there's a
i like i fully believe in venting
i think venting is part of the process
of being human being
and um having social situations but
when there's no when you just want to
complain
to kind of talk [ __ ] about someone i can
start i start feeling like
oh yeah
no no let's uplift our yeah and
which is so funny yeah again couldn't
couldn't be two bigger pieces [ __ ]
um but that's the that's the
so again it's all ayahuasca promo at
this point
but um
[Music]
do just do it in a safe environment and
know that it
it uh whether it's a
amazing experience or a trying
experience it will be
incredibly beneficial and also know that
it'll be over in four hours whatever
happens
or in bianca's case seven but she had a
second cup guys
once you get that second cup i had a
taste of that second cup um
this is different but i'm do you do a
second cup i'm just saying that's why
hers lasted long um
should we should we do just the last one
because it seems more yeah fun yeah
yeah um
big fan of the pod and i really dig it
when you all talk about compelling works
uh works and art and junk regardless of
the medium
i was wondering what would be your three
desert eye deserted island discs
um to to keep you company in the realm
of comedy film
documentaries if is
is your that you're into them i guess
guys you'd kind of [ __ ] with me and
bianca when you don't proofread these
letters makes us look stupid
it's true um dvd box uh you can allow
dvd box sets
when it comes to shows i guess maybe
season arcs maybe i don't
what just say what are your [ __ ] what
are you talking about like our
goddamn caveats um
i'm gonna go we'll go comedy special
okay yeah comedy special give like a few
let's just do this and documentary
comedy special i would go
chris rock bring the pain i would do
dave chappelle
kill him softly i would do patrice
o'neill elves in the room
do bill hicks the england one
i would do uh the one where he's wearing
a hat and they
he comes out to a bad jimi hendrix cover
uh like the sound alike it's called and
bill burr
[Music]
one of bill's specials i'd put on there
and those uh just leave it
i could yeah
like he's killed [ __ ] on and on jim
jeffries
right yeah that's the problem like i
would do
much i said patrice right you said i do
patrice dave
chris i you know i [ __ ]
love early um cat williams
it's i can cry i can just
watch them over and over obviously
you're not alone by the way they're
so funny yeah the i don't know i forgot
the names because
well it's been feminine there's another
pimp one yeah
green suit yeah that's it's pimping
pitman that's his finger
it's fitment paper is so funny
yeah it's just yeah it's fine um
yeah i feel like we're on the same page
yeah uh
documentary the movie
you know one movie it's like it's
categorical but
wall street oliver stone is a movie i
think about all the [ __ ] times
i watched it so many times why
uh because it's good and bad writing
it's good it truly is good in bed
writing like there's the greatest good
speech
which is a hall of famer and then
there's also
like charlie sheen
like standing out looking over the city
in his new apartment
on his [ __ ] wacky cell phone like
there's like that's bad writing and then
there's
there's like an argument between charlie
sheen and his dad on an elevator that's
[ __ ]
killer yeah uh like i don't go to sleep
with no [ __ ] and i don't wake up with
one it's like
nice um and
and then there's city of god and the
apartment
and uh team america
and uh you know things things of that
nature
i i can't do the movies this is too
overwhelming there's too much but
also i wouldn't i wouldn't i don't like
watching movies over again
i can watch a movie once even in high
school
what do you mean in high school it's
what else are you doing
we just watch movies over now uh no i'm
watching new movies
like half baked friday mm-hmm i get it
half faked friday so funny i always
think people are
for us my first instinct is she's
[ __ ] on you
what not like what not not
literally but like
what's wrong with you not you when
someone mentions this at a
as a thing that they watch over and over
again i'm like
i had the op that's my getting shot in a
in a massage parlor like
that's the opposite of my experience
with it i know and it's like
oddly enough it's brought a lot of
people joy i know
i know um it's so much greater than you
will
allow yourself god bless enjoy um
but yeah so i'm not i don't like
watching movies over again so i'd be i'd
watch it twice and never touch it so
more tv just save room for more tv
interesting like sopranos i can watch
over and over again
haven't but could you have never watched
it no i haven't watched it over again
you could i know i know i could because
i people who tell me that they watch it
over and over again i'm like yeah that
makes sense
uh i just can go with the storyline in a
tv arc easier than it's just the
movie's done so quick yeah um
sopran like all the regular ones that
everybody watches but
i like weird like spin city and news
radios
i'm like give me a good 90s
like just shoot me i love right there
like they're not bad they're good but
they're like nowhere
disposable they're disposable and i
they're so mindless
i love them uh i don't think i've
watched
maybe a scene of just shoot me
what i i remember watching just shoot me
and thinking i mean when it was on going
like
spade picked this one right because that
show got picked up
it was they did the pilot it got picked
up
then they added spade so spade didn't
have to do the pilot
or risk anything and he just was like
go in you're gonna have 13 lines an
episode and you're going to get
13 laps and a lot of money
yeah well that's the other thing it's
like probably a hundred grand an episode
and
at that age yeah like at that age
but no if he would just shoot me is so
funny
just shoot me mama's family like i just
like old family
i love old american tv if i could
i used to take all these um television
history classes
in college i just we would just watch
like sid caesar
like i just like old television you can
watch it forever
you ever watch it and go uh everyone on
screen
well everyone's racist everyone on
screen everyone laughing
all dead yeah i do that with um i watch
often i watch a english show called are
you being served and
it makes me really sad i can't think of
it i'm like
it's like the it's like it's like the
shining it's like the shining the hotel
picture
where they're like that you hear the
music and it's like having a
legitimately great time like hey
dead unspeakable but if you learn
nothing else from this episode death
is not a period death my friends
is a comma bianca take this [ __ ] no more
let's get the [ __ ] out goodbye
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
you